[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
on the road i i try to eat go to good
restaurants because i want to i want to
at least like feel the city
you won't eat like dominoes or anything
well whenever you domino's because we
live in new york [ __ ] city where i
can eat great pizza on any corn why
would a dominoes when we can get better
slice than any corner man oh sure but
i'm saying if you're in that [ __ ]
city no i don't i won't eat pizza on the
road unless they've got a good road
pizza spot like if i'm in new haven
connecticut i'll eat you don't ever like
hate yourself after a scent and just get
pizza hut or something
i've done it but it's like i usually
will like panda express bring it on yeah
yeah i i stop the asian hate exactly
here here is that real let's talk about
it in asia
imagine i go into it let's talk about
the rock he's a transphobe
i yeah um yeah i guess i don't really i
don't know look guys i've always been
thin since i've known i've known you my
whole i've known you since 2000 i've
known both you guys since like 12 years
now well you guys we're like significant
parts of each other's lives
yeah it's wild i've known you for so
long to know somebody for 12 13 years
you know like and to like someone for
that how insane i know how like how
insane that is you may not see each
other all the time but it's like the
fact that like we very well could be in
each other's lives for like 30 years
that's why i invited everybody to the
wedding because i'm like i've seen all
these [ __ ] grow kids no kids
married who's somebody who's somebody if
you just [ __ ] say it we're drunk
who's somebody that just missed the cut
come on mark all right cosby
what are the highlights give me another
highlighted cops while you look it up
just says going off air keeps hurting me
keeps on hurting me
ah
cops eyes let me think that i mean
there's so many you know what i mean
like i'm sorry
uh anytime somebody gets
uh
clearly rested for prostitution and
trying to say
that's not what it is us particularly we
don't have the prostitutes
uh
like they pull a prostitute aside
and when the prostitute admits it
sometimes
the prostitute will be like yeah you
know me officer whatever like yeah i was
i'm just trying you know i ain't doing
drugs no more i'm just trying to get off
the street and they're just talking to
some [ __ ] sad old man and i go why'd
you pick up hogs hooker no no no that's
my uh that's my it's my sister's kid
you're just like trying to give some
kind of thing hook and the cooker's just
totally like
yeah i'll go in the night i could
probably i could bond out tonight right
is that cool and the conflict yeah yeah
that's fine you can fail out tonight oh
yeah then the guys over there like she
said she was a hooker and i agreed to
that no
no that's just that's cannot be right
and then anytime they have the cops pose
as i feel bad with the cops for whatever
reason i feel bad when the cops pose as
john's and get the hookers oh really
i do yeah it seems like a victimless
crime it is a victimless crime and
they're just like they're the victims
they're such sad individuals like
they're not even they're not even like
what i'm saying they wouldn't but in
that crime they're not even like robbing
a place or stealing someone's goods
they're like
i'll put anyone's [ __ ] in my mouth for
just enough money to feel
good for a little bit
damn man hurting
damn it just sucks
you don't pay taxes what's your issue if
you go to lake county california
it's like it's like williamsburg of bad
white [ __ ] like it knows about
everything before anyone else like
they're the hipsters on white trash like
like methamphetamines were real big
before
i get all the cheetos before everybody
else yeah your brother brother we've had
cinnamon mountain dew for about six
years now
[ __ ] i didn't know he could do that
first first county to have the combo
dude forever lake county will now be
in my head as a mountain dew test market
you've seen some dead bodies we the only
actually one we saw the only one i can
remember seeing recently something like
that is when we're on we're in la a few
months ago and it was me
vinnie and and the two kids and in the
back and we saw like a car fire and i
was just like oh like everything like i
was like you know my daughter was like
mad scared she was like oh my god like
no don't go past it but we had no choice
we were driving down the freeway we had
to and then and then i was like it's
just a car on fire like you know it's
fine in my step someone's in the back
too it was like it's legitimately fine
i'm sure they're out of the car like but
was pillars of smoke but we were driving
by and i swear we just saw a guy in the
driver's seat body just like just a
black carcass just in flames
just burned to a chris with his hands on
the wheel and my daughter said oh my god
and my son was like that's awesome
i swear to god like literally like i
talked about on the andrew santino
whiskey ginger podcast also your
daughter brought it up to me constantly
yeah we were driving around yeah she's
still she's terrified yeah and then the
carvel in our neighborhood burnt down
and we weren't there was that guy from
going down with the ship though i know a
lot of people a lot of cowards would
have abandoned he was like i'm not like
i'm like this is captain's honor yeah he
was like
this corolla's but nothing but great to
me he's been a brother to me
dude he literally
feels like he's [ __ ] doing chris
i wonder if he was like depressed that
as soon as this fire started he was like
you know what [ __ ]
[ __ ] it this is it
i don't want to live in biden's america
dude and he and literally yeah my
daughter she's still like the carvel
burnt down and she thinks now anything
that's ever on fire that guy's in it
she's always like is the man in there
she you know it's funny she calls she
calls me there and dude she calls him
the black man so i'm like you have to
like no call him like the burnt man or
the crispy call him something else
she's like the black man
[Music]
yes knew it in his heart bro
white people know all m words
dude
theo man that [ __ ] came a long
way
look how adorable it was when he was
younger the rat king dropping m bombs at
seven so i think he was surprised that
people clapped when he said it he was
like oh [ __ ] yeah
i want to see the shot of the kids
in the background when he spelled it
like that and a few of them are gonna be
like
and then later you learned that clinton
and gore together
learned how to go for business and tell
big business look we're gonna make you a
fortune don't worry about the social
issues we're gonna take care of the poor
we're gonna do all kinds of programs but
we're getting rid of wealth he got rid
of welfare and he was also a um
a death penalty governor yeah
he put a [ __ ] guided
electorate
he put a [ __ ] guy in the electorate
chair
when he was governor he literally just
like he was drunk and he said come here
and he's like
what are you doing and he just took him
he put him in it and he said never mind
she's [ __ ] shut up
killed a [ __ ] guy single-handedly
do you think you could turn not to a
life of crime but do you think
your circumstances are pure you don't
intend to hurt anybody yeah but do you
think you could do something like that i
couldn't shoot somebody but you don't
know where your next meal is coming from
you got a family
oh he's got you there and look we're not
we're not women we can't do only fans
you're lucky ladies that's the only fans
that lost money
good teacher really seems to care
why watch seinfeld i thought i don't
like
it's like three episodes i know like if
i watched the whole thing there'd be
three where i'd be like oh yeah now this
one i don't know the show very well at
all but i remember when i like when i
see things i think it's funny oh yeah i
love it it's not even that's he's just
pompous that's like my one problem with
bill cosby he's great but he's pompous
that's the one thing that's the one
thing
that's it dude
the other stuff meet a flawless human
being and there's just one thing holding
them back it's his pompacity
yeah
he thinks too high of himself
besides that guy's walking on sunshine
i got rocked in the face by my college
girlfriend from the back seat for what
i went to a movie without her because he
made her sit in the backseat
no i wasn't drunk
i was sitting in the passenger seat my
buddy was driving she was in the back
seat and just came around
full full punch right in the side of the
face you went to the movies without her
yeah what movie uh i want to say it was
one of the batman's
this girl sounds like a real [ __ ] i'm
telling you and she was like pow
[Laughter]
what's your goal
for personal training
not no real set goal right now would
happen what would happen if you started
getting ripped would you still i would
have to stop yeah although at that point
i'm sure it would be too powerful if you
bulked if you bulked in this quiet guy
i got to be honest with you based on
today's performance
we're a decade away
for a decade
you got a lot of to work with you know
yeah i mean i gotta you can convert just
where i want to muscle yeah did the
trainer ask you if you have big balls
do you think that's funny to make fun of
me
[Laughter]
why do you think i'm insecure about my
big balls dude i'm not
you laugh it up dude
you have a good laugh sean
you got you got big balls
mine are mine are getting bad what do
you mean they're just starting to go
lower and lower your baggies yeah
like i'm embarrassed because you're
confident
yeah dude i still have a boyish tucked
in sack
that's crazy
no if it's warm though like oh yeah the
sheath draws them loose dude the sheath
makes them just a pillow they're the
bean bag yeah dude if it's if it's warm
out the dog drops his tongue
that's a cartoon dog coke rolls it down
yeah the dog drops it's like it's like
humming to a snail on the beach look at
us now drunk on uh weird martinis
[ __ ] weird studio i know we're
drinking water i knew you'd like the
patrick ewing thing yeah so patrick let
me tell you my patrick hearings
so i got two of them he's got any you
could feed chris anything and you'll
have something i'm trying to hear your
harvey weinstein story
he touched
and he said your heart's beating so
quickly
so
patrick ewing my very first knicks came
how old were you
9 10. so i was a little kid you know
early 90s you know we're sitting you
know whatever upper deck seats whatever
patrick ewing goes baseline and like
tomahawk dunks on shaquille o'neal and i
was like oh my god and then he like you
know shaquille had like fallen under him
so like patrick had to like hang on the
rim a little bit so i go dad i like
standable's like i was like patrick
ewing i was like dad look at him he's
swinging on the rim like a big monkey
like that because to me it looked like a
monkey and my dad was just like pulling
me down pushing me down and everyone was
like looking over at me like whatever
and then my dad i
there's a thing i don't know if i try to
do like
misremember this because i thought it
was like a a a funny or i thought it was
like some type of defense mechanism but
i'm almost positive like i would be
willing to say i'm 95 sure this he
really said this is he looked around
because he got tense like oh really he
got yeah because i just yelled up and
said he's like a monkey and went well
the black face didn't help yeah
yeah
and you know it's bad when you offend
yeah early 90s new york yeah and then my
dad i was going to say it was 92-93 my
dad like said to like the general group
around he goes my son's [ __ ]
good save good not special needs nothing
because my son's [ __ ] so he made it
by the way by the way his save is now
would make it 10 times worse right yeah
yeah
that's genius time that's a great it's
like what kevin spacey did he's he
[ __ ] that kid he was like well i'm
autistic yeah he said i'm gay or i'm
getting
help
you can't say it you can't be accused of
[ __ ] someone underage and be like i'm
gay that's not a sexual orientation
thing so kevin spacey well let me tell
you about kevin spacey
[Laughter]
it would have been great to have like a
late seventies
cops early eighties cops like popeye
doyle you'd have just you could never
trust an n-word
you kind of like legit
abusive power video because that that
was the time they wouldn't even have
cared about it's you seeing it
dude there was a show that was chicago
pd or one of the shows there black guy
for real be like what are you doing in
this neighborhood and they would show it
on tv he goes look at these guys keeping
our neighborhoods safe exactly
there was a chicago one of those cop
shows on like cbs something like that
and the it was like four or five years
ago and it was like uh they don't play
by the rules and then people like hey
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] like the
audience was like that's awful and like
oh what like yeah man we don't
as a group of society we don't want that
anymore
like oh they had to change the whole
marketing campaign we don't play by the
way it's like no we need you to play but
you guys have to play by the strictest
of rules
the letter of the law
that was a dirty hairy thing it was like
i'll go rogue i'll do my own thing and
now it's like don't ever do that
let me get people get jacked up because
he plays by his own you cost the city
thirty five thousand dollars of
destroyed properties so what i thought
the guy goes that's a major problem
that's a budgeting nightmare what do you
mean what's who cares you can't just
shoot willy nilly at stuff
[Laughter]
i've caught the guy yeah
i shot him from the i shot him from the
floor of the mall he was on the third
balcony you can't just shoot there was a
shotgun
i never miss you might miss
that's not gonna fly in court yeah i
never met uh i submit to you that he's
never missed i hope you're enjoying this
video so far just real quick i want to
ask you to comment who your favorite new
york comedian is who's been funniest in
this video and any new york podcast that
i missed that you think should be in
part two there is gonna be a part two so
make sure you subscribe to joke world
right now turn on those post
notifications so you don't miss part two
because how embarrassing would it be if
you saw part one and then you missed
part two people are making fun of you
out in the street oh you saw the joke
world best in new york comics part one
but you didn't see part two i don't want
that to happen to anybody that would be
terrible let's avoid all that drama
let's avoid all that harassment oh you
don't subscribe to joke world no you can
change that right now i know it's tough
out there for non-subscribers so i'm
just looking out for you guys subscribe
to joke world stay safe and enjoy the
rest of the video you tricked me i like
because i sit like that too and it does
mean you got a small dick and i love
when the head just kind of peeks out
between the legs just like that because
it's nice and cozy and yeah i keep the
balls below and the head up yeah but you
guys you got to separate it
yeah it's like a sailboat i have a time
my penises look small it looks like
chewing gum in a jufrown
[Laughter]
you know like when a soldier loses an
arm and he's got like a nub my dick
looks like a knife that little skin
hanging off there
it looks like a bomb blew off my dick
putin sometimes pulls my heart strings
i'll make a case and i'm like
dude you remember that motorcycle gang
for his security in the adam curtis
stock that [ __ ] that's pulling my
[ __ ] heart that kind of [ __ ] rule
they were they were like remember the
swords of your grandfather the eurasian
it was like yo do you remember he's our
problem he banned i think recently
banned pornhub allegedly he banned
pornhub was like go meet someone in real
life no i swear to god look it up
guardian look it up
what the [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] rules
he banned pornhub and it was like
knocking the [ __ ] off yeah go get a
[ __ ] dude people are going to be
incentivized to have kids pretty shortly
30 years or so they're going to be like
come on let's go yeah we need i i don't
like it we i'm with bill gates dude we
need to depopulate we are we're
definitely we're on course great uh bill
gate wasn't his dad allegedly a genesis
yeah allegedly of course that's bill
gates [ __ ] motto but i even heard him
he really piped down yeah he's shut up
dude yeah he really played shut up dork
i think we should have done it what
someone should have been like shut the
[ __ ] up does he get pied in the face
dude someone picked he became a little
angry dork after he got pied
who pied him i don't know a [ __ ] lone
pieman
he [ __ ] bite him right in the [ __ ]
baker dude
i gotta show you this pie
pornography is banned in russia
pornhub and you porn
uh authorities have told citizens to
meet people in real life direct quotes
yeah yes they have a whole uh bill gates
pie in face you can google this is a
good week
that might be the intro no this is very
old this is right when he begins he was
like we need to depopulate
let me see
this is a great pie
oh
[Laughter]
i think he would have avoided that pie
there's nothing you could do to avoid
that pie dude if he had played sports it
came around a pillar
we would be more aware
i always do if i'm walking around a
pillar i'm [ __ ] checking for pies
that gunman dude carrying a pie all day
just standing behind a pillar with a pie
people had to walk by like no way
no way
what's he doing with that did he not
just holding a cream pie dude
that's also like how do you know where
bill gates is going he was ready
he stalked him
he fought bill gates's cp
absolute
my grandma is still in that you know she
still lives up there and that's where my
dad went from being like
a couch alcoholic that worked at a
liquor store but still could get it
together enough to get 49ers tickets
from his garbage
delivery from the garbage man i swear to
god teddy the garbage man god gave us
niners tickets and we went it was like
steve young's first start against the
rams really yeah it was like back when
montana got traded to the chiefs it was
unbelievable
and
dude teddy the garbage man gave us like
always shady when you have a personal
relationship with the garbage man what
are you doing in the nine seconds that
he's out front of your house
teddy my dad was like i'm very much my
father's personality which is just like
hey you want to talk i'll talk to you
for [ __ ] three hours yeah and uh and
then i find out that the mob
like really runs the garbage in san
francisco like really way beyond new
york obviously waste management but like
san francisco the mob had a stranglehold
on
the [ __ ] collection yeah collection
and then i realized teddy was like a
good-looking italian kid
this kid was probably [ __ ] mobbed and
that's why we got like
20th row 40 yard line tickets to the
niners
of a liquor store in mill valley
so we used to like that's great
no child support but steve young comes
up to you after
to get the high five good to see you
it's a high five huey lewis in his prime
uh and he's only throwing out guys in
rolled up carpets yeah
teddy gives my dad manila envelope and
he goes like hey why don't you get this
[ __ ] off your back
why don't you kick a little to that
noisy [ __ ] in colorado
he's into what the ninja turtles what
are they called he goes by the way we
can stop by and make life for his
stepfather very painful
i got some people in aurora it's okay he
goes listen i got a cousin he's out in
aurora because he's got a hot sheet
right now he's laying low but he can
still do something all i'm saying is
it'd be a shame
if your son's stepfather had a broken
hip do you ever like try to recreate the
night as with your memories and slowly
make your feelings get worse about what
yeah that's what's happening here today
today i'm thinking back on the podcast
like jesus yeah i know i remember during
the show being like this is great try to
remember this this is a nice moment i
like uh oh yeah i like when uh we were
like what should we do on roger we're
like let's run the [ __ ] over him let's
control that goddamn puck hey i snored
on him he did that was great was wild he
was like
stuck with him dude he brought it up
later
wow
that's a good one that's what you know
it's a good one for people like still
feeling it way later but i mean he gets
blown all day long it must be nice to
get [ __ ] on i think that's what i'm
saying he brought it up as like it was a
good thing he was like okay he was like
that was a fun podcast let's do it
whenever and he was like he does guys
for once
all right
yeah it's like a hot chick who gets just
you know waited on hand and foot that
one guy's mean to her and she's like i
wanna [ __ ] him i have seen comments that
i like they're like yeah burn oreo like
the only guys that [ __ ] throw yeah
yeah these were just friends they're
supposed to i do those youtube shorts
and they all get like 10 views but then
i put one of me calling rogan fed and
hit 2 million
people like when you [ __ ] on that twink
i mean if in front of people it's always
fun
yeah
twink
but he's a little he's like a bear twink
that's true a beast yeah
yeah
yeah is that like a small hairy yeah
like matteo is an otter yeah he's
hairless
no he's italian he's got some chest hair
does he oh it's a small a small hairless
is a twink that's a twink what's a big
hairless that's a bear oh
i guess i'm a seal or a sea lion your
seal or sea lion yeah yeah yeah which
also
listen i was gonna do a fat choke cause
you're fat but i'm not gonna do it it's
all right
you're old
you're so [ __ ] old dude
i can't wait for you to die before me i
don't know i think it's gonna be a race
between the two of us that had a heart
attack i hope you accidentally do
fentanyl at this comedy festival god i
can't wait to douse you on purpose with
fentanyl i
dude dude what do you think the odds are
that somebody legitimately i think
there's a high chance someone overdosed
[Music]
i brought some yeah dude well that's
solid it's a good podcast
i need a topic real quick you need a
topic yeah
i don't know what was the 1920s like
damn it dude
what was it like the moment of the
roaring 20s
how's that model t dude i threw up a
picture of me in a in college and people
like oh where'd you get that throwback
pepsi cam
good for them for banning pornography
it's that's nice for the people dude you
get to revert back to for the people you
get to revert back to like magazines
yeah dude going into a gas station
buying a [ __ ] porno dude i do shower
beats now it's just pure
that's nice pure yeah purely in the
[ __ ]
i miss beats dude i've been with my lady
too much yeah i haven't been beaten at
all tell you need me time
i like to save my seed for my lady dude
that you have to save it forever you
have to man but you must i'm i'm ready
for a good me time here's some me though
you're gonna be on the road wait i'm
gonna
like crazy i'm in providence this
weekend me time
[Laughter]
i'm i'm busting in there it is crazy
though if you're if you're having sex
regularly and you finally get the jerk
off it is like does rule nice especially
hiding on the couch when she's in the
bedroom
you go mommy don't catch me
i moved to new york 10 years ago was 82
a month for a subway pass now it's like
115. yeah service has gotten worse costs
have gone up like 30 40 percent yeah so
service gets worse and you're charging
me more money yeah how do why would i
trust you with more money but they got
the let me do a little
but i will say this
uh
incredible point about the astonishing
increase in price in the last [ __ ] 10
years and they're going broke absurd
they're still going broke let me ask you
this if we were on a [ __ ] chairlift
skiing right and the chairlift people
said hold on there's a little traffic on
the chairlift
right
you'd be like what you mean is traffic
it's just one thing it just goes up and
it comes down it can't be traffic
because it just goes up and it comes
down right like that would be the answer
right
you cannot physically have traffic
because it's just one
whenever i see traffic it's when four
lanes turn into two yeah but you always
have there's more people at
the s
what's it called ski lift or whatever
ski lift who doesn't know how to get off
the [ __ ] thing yeah and then they
have to stop it because that
[ __ ] falls right out and they're
smart and they stop the whole [ __ ] yeah
they don't let the whole [ __ ] go and
then it backs up and then we got 14
lifts about to go and then more
accidents happen yes that's what trade
traffic is that's what you should do
stop the whole [ __ ] just stop the train
just close the door like yo you can't
swipe remember when we were young we had
little train tracks and you had the
little cars set up on the train tracks
there was traffic there
you ain't never was you never in your
life were playing with your train tracks
and you were like mom
oh my god there's too much traffic
i don't expect how simple he can make
[ __ ] sound without making any sense
what i'm saying is you have to be next
level [ __ ]
to make traffic on yo when the guy on
the mic goes there's a little traffic
ahead how
how is the traffic ahead let me guess
how many trains is ahead
one
because that's how many could fit
it makes me go [ __ ] crazy
how many
like how could there be traffic guys
look look ready look there's there's two
there's one track and there's only yeah
let's do a visual though ready there's
one track right here's one train
there's traffic ahead you telling me we
got that
you're telling me we got one on top of
the other is that what managed to happen
did we manage at union square to get two
four trains on top of each other because
otherwise it's impossible to have
traffic it's not possible
when they say it i go crazy when they
say it i lose my [ __ ] my when they
say i want to knock on the door i go
prove it
prove it
show me a picture of the traffic
show i want to see picture of a bunch of
guys in the front of the traffic light
all the train drivers
son this is how you know there's no
traffic they ain't got horns on the
train
because the people who make the train
don't think about the two that's
emergency i'm talking about beep beep
they don't got bb
they got a baby
the people who made trains knew there
wasn't gonna be no [ __ ] trash
right they probably asked him like oh
should we put a beep and he goes how
could there be traffic it's one [ __ ]
lane
and then these retards manage to find a
way to make traffic
make traffic authority that's what mta
stands for
[Laughter]
that's what it stands for make traffic
authorities oh my god how you managed to
make traffic
yeah it's like if a movie started late
at the movie theater just press play
what time the movie
hey guess what you do at eight play
i'm sorry the movie's running a little
late take your finger
and press play and then it's on time yo
you had a lot of flavor it takes you
shiny
what the [ __ ] and if we let this goofy
[ __ ] elizabeth warren run [ __ ]
mta
just imagine you grew up in new orleans
yeah treme which is like uh like in new
york the new orleans pronouncing it new
orleans is like the way new yorkers say
houston and everybody else goes houston
street yes we go new orleans yes guys
it's one word it's north
new orleans yeah it just kind of rolls
comes with like a hint of slavery
[Laughter]
yes labor was big now you guys got some
[ __ ] hall of fame plantations down
there oh beautiful i mean we go to those
weddings if i ever did the bachelor i'd
be kicked off because of all the
antebellum [ __ ] i was involved in yeah
don't do your wedding right now that's
the thing ryan reynolds got in trouble
right because yeah he had his wedding at
a plantation but my thing is like the
rules weren't set there that was just
like it was a beautiful kind of
thing you know yeah it was just rich
people who had slaves and land and they
had to till the field and servants and
all that so
obviously it was bad but the places are
beautiful these are big pillars with the
fence and the yard it's great but you
got i do kind of agree though it is kind
of like if you look at it from their
perspective it's like you're getting
married it's like what's the difference
between getting married there and
getting married um well you could say i
had a slave at a slave house
but auschwitz isn't pretty no that's
true you know so you think if austria's
was put pretty like yeah hell yeah i
mean that's uh cook some wood fire
that's a big oven you got a good pizza
going
come on jesse jackson
attacked cedric the entertainer many
years later for a character he played in
barbershop where he says [ __ ] rosa parks
everyone i'm sick of hearing about
rosebud it's a really funny scene where
he's a black guy saying i don't give a
[ __ ] about rosa parks and uh jesse
jackson um said he never should have
said that she's a you know uh you don't
touch this woman with your humor and
he's yelled at and and cedric
was a religious guy and you know he was
upset and i was pissed off with jesse
and i just did some once in a while i do
this kind of dumb thing i called the
[ __ ] uh his the rainbow coalition
that's his office in chicago and this
woman answered the phone hello and i go
i have a complaint about jesse jackson
she goes who are you
i said i'm just a citizen and i don't
agree with what she said he says he
don't care what you think young man
yeah
that's good yeah because you know
sometimes i've called the white house
like four times in my life and said hey
you know
and they say yes tell me the thing and
they politely take it down i called
trump
when trump was like not
not conceding the election yeah i called
the white house and it was deep into it
and usually it's like hello white house
it's a switchboard offering
and you say i want to make a complaint
she says yes i'll put you through they
either you know they give you a
voicemail or they put somebody who just
writes down thank you very much they
take your comment and you just figure
it's one of a trillion
but when i called trump's white house
some guy you could hear a loosened tie
and no and shea unshaven somebody goes
hello
white house and i go hi i want to make a
complaint he goes what
i want to make him play goes ah look um
please just go to the website can you
just go to the website and i said i said
are you okay and he goes not great i
swear to god i had this conversation he
was not great i said okay well i hope
you have a better day he said thank you
i do appreciate that so it was
at that point the white house was in a
place where it was like trump's like
somebody get the [ __ ] phone the
[ __ ] phone is ruined it's like
nobody's left it was the end of a wolf
of wall street yeah everybody just
thought about it
what would you rather do eat mcdonald's
for 30 days straight or do shrooms 30
days straight
how much shrooms shane's like that's
another seven days of mcdonald's
did i ever tell you about the story of
what happened when somebody wronged my
mother by
i got the story for you too right after
this my house got robbed while i was in
it we're gonna go back to back yeah go
back to back right now i got yeah
so my
uncle victor r.i.p r.i.p love you
uh
somebody was there was a a ring going
around somebody was somebody was robbing
like women's purses in my neighborhood
oh there was a crime ring crime ring
going around
going around robbing women's purses
right in my neighborhood so off of the
women in the street like ripping them
off their shoulder right and then you
know muggings right and then
selling or you know
the the ring the criminal enterprise
ring was was being dealt with out of the
back of a bodega that was on my corner
so the back of the bodega on my corner
it was a hot spot they were stealing
bags and they you know money selling
whatever did you know this i'm gonna
tell you okay
so
my uncle
my uncle used to hang out all the time
in this bodega and i had credit at that
bodega because they knew that i was his
his nephew through marriage so i go in
there get you know a cheese you know
sandwich and soda i'd say put this on
uncle victor's tab and they would say
okay because they knew they knew that
he's good for it because i'm victor's
kid i'm victor's uh you know uh nephew
through marriage so they were like it's
all good okay so then one time so they
were like okay okay i'm reloaded you
know you selling scarface yeah it was
the yeah so it was the guys in the
bodegas so
one day
somebody steals my mother's purse off
the shoulder my mother pushes oh my god
pushes my own mother to the ground
steals her mug steals her purse she got
mugged
shows up to the house hands bleeding
from from being thrown to the floor oh
yeah god that's bad
bag ripped off the shoulder my mother
did manage this one was shot on my mom
she did manage
shout out she had her uh purse on her
left shoulder she had our dinner which
was uh uh from wendy's in her right hand
she dropped the soda but she was able to
keep my chicken nuggets and a small
cheeseburger oh god and served it to me
and it's unbelievable i didn't get the
frosty that i wanted but shout out when
you shout out
shout out chilly nice chili on that one
but my mom still that's how you know and
you know that's how you know like and by
the way today is international women's
day whenever this episode comes out so i
just want to give a shout out to my
mother is is you you i'll never forget
that you did feed me that night even
though you just got mugged you saved the
wendy's you sacrificed your purse but
you said you're not one thing you're not
getting is my son's chicken nuggets with
a small fry no no no you're not getting
that chicken nuggets a small fry for all
purposes to you way more valuable in her
purse yeah i was like mom i don't care
that you lost your social security card
that means nothing to me i'm 9. i was
going to say i was going to say was she
like did she handle it was she like this
[ __ ] grabbed my thing and ran i
screamed but i couldn't wish did she go
home like oh she came out to stay
indoors
it was one of those things she was like
i just i just was mugged somebody stole
my purse and then my my aunt who we live
she's like call 9-1-1 you know whatever
and then and then i was like oh my god
what happened and then my mom has the
wendy's and she's like here i have your
dinner so so i'm like ugh so i'm eating
you know you're like i'm like yeah i'm
like mom you you the barbecue sauce you
know i want extra
you know how good wendy's barbecue sauce
is and two sauces mom so my uncle says
my uncle says
what you know what did this guy look
like whatever like that he knows where
to go he knows where the chop shop is
for the purses so i said so you know she
says oh you know you look like this this
and this he goes i think i think i may
know what's going on here he goes do me
a favor don't call the cops i think i
can handle this whoa this is all sweet
it got true
so then
we is this the guy who used to rip your
heart out of your chest from temple of
doom no that's uncle johnny this is this
is tio because he's a different guy it
would be great if he went down there
we'll dig and start
but uncle johnny did still have his his
his uh his uniform from korea that had
holes and blood in it and he said this
is what real men do and then he showed
me his bloody uniform i was like
you know okay
i know i was like i was like i i was
like i want to put on your daughter's
makeup
you know so
so so he says you know don't you know
just i'll uh i'll take care of this
so maybe an hour to go by right
he comes back with the purse he has the
purse he said listen the money is
already gone i couldn't get the money
back but you don't have to cancel your
credit cards or your license or whatever
i have the purse back and then they're
like oh my god what happened you know
whatever all this and he's like ah you
know i got the purse back i knew who who
did it
so fine whatever he gets the purse back
okay so many questions let's continue
he gets the purse back
then
i don't i just forget about this
incident for
you know years
fast forward i'm like late teens or
early 20s
my uncle victor
they're talking about something they're
like oh remember that time when somebody
stole
you know my mother's purse you know that
guy really got what was coming to him so
i was like what do you mean what's
coming to him like i never heard of it i
thought you just got the purse back like
what happened he goes well what happened
was is i
went to the bodega
new digital anti-justice yeah he goes i
went to the bodega he goes i knew
who had stolen the purse he goes he
wasn't there because he just was
dropping the purse off he says i
to get the stolen goods back he said
listen i know the woman whose purse she
stole it's going to be really bad she
knows that things are going on back here
so just give me the purse you know i'll
take care of everything else but just
give me the purse i'll give it back to
he didn't say it was his is his
sister-in-law or anything like that so
he gets the first back that night i had
no idea he went and got drunk with the
guy who stole my mother's purse he was
sure of gets him drunk he takes him to
our garage which was detached from our
house he my uncle was a welder and
worked with tools
tied him up in our garage for two days
and melted the skin off his kneecaps
with his welding blowtorch
how have you never told me this story
how you never told me this story
what are you talking about he blew did i
tell you this pamela you just implicated
your uncles to go to [ __ ] he's dead
you're uncle's daddy i told you he died
oh my god alright forgot about that
yeah he died he died of cancer he said
no meds i'm going out
what crazy
hey these are better than they look dude
dude honestly man i need a second one
yeah we might need more ice matt if
that's possible i spilled some of it on
my jeans thank god they were eight
dollars um
i mean whatever company sent does this
[ __ ] uh yeah 1888 hey man this is a good
year that's oliver i'm watching that
show 1883 by the way
it's on apple tv phenomenal show is that
the year bind was
there it born
all right yeah it's not bad um what what
trying to keep them joking here wait
what can we focus yes i have two points
and lewis has points okay go ahead
my two points are one i just because i
feel shame after i'm very open sexually
i talk everything i'm openly have herpes
i like you know you should literally
take that mic with you you don't need to
help that out
we're going to lose viewers
you have missed my shame there's a
reason no one admits to it dude just be
one of the people that don't talk about
it ah just like everybody
like the rest of us which is my camera i
like eating ass i like spitting my mouth
i want my you know i want to be uh oh
not yours god that is gross maxed out on
deadlifts maxed out on bench jesus man
no wonder you're well it was just it was
just to see where we're at true like a
starting point like it wasn't like i
wasn't in there like yeah you're just
like although on bench i was that was
sad it's too hard hit two i had to add
two and a half so i was like dude i'm
not doing 195. no bro gotta hit 200.
this is how's the chest feel then it's
uh it's a little a little sore today
that's how do presses too
i've never looked more yeah i know it's
a running gag a lot of people think it's
a big joke to say that i look like i
have some type of mental disability
you guys see me doing a [ __ ] straight
bar press
oh you're doing funny
some one wrote a thing under my comments
today
i guess the post they put up today for
me was something about a
settling down young
yeah it says i don't even remember what
it was for my special i don't know it
might have been working
yeah i don't remember what the bit is
but that's what the title is of that
okay yeah
it's called settling down young
and someone goes like oh yeah great
advice from someone who cheated their
entire relationship this whole thing is
like yeah you know that because i've
talked about it and said like yeah it
was shitty and did i was i'm like what
are you what yeah
do you know what i mean it's just a
weird thing people like
you know and then the fans just like the
fan jumping they're like uh he's spoken
like he's aware of his mistakes and i'm
like i'm like you know i feel you
you only wear them because i told you
that's why i hated when the yankees
would get on um who was it where it's
like who's your daddy
um that great pitcher for red sox
pedro martinez yeah okay you kept
getting beat in the playoffs by them by
the yankees yeah and then eventually
he's like you know sometimes you gotta
just [ __ ]
say like you know just call them your
daddy and move on you think they got you
they got your number and they'd be like
who's your jet like they uncovered
something and i wonder guys it's his
quote
you're using it you're using his quote
against him same exact thing he said you
got me
exactly this guy cheated his whole
marriage and blah blah blah yeah also
what what are you way into the sanctity
of marriage yeah it's like why are you
so worried about my and by the way goes
are you looking at my comedy show as
relationship advice or whatever that's
why i see people when they're like i'm
never going to support this dude again
because he went on the wrong side of
comedy he said somewhat so like went too
far and i'm like oh guys
that's not why you should be going to
see somebody's comedy show
yeah the other views yeah you really
should just be like what kind of show
they put on it's almost the only thing
really do i like their comedy yeah and
that is why i pay fifteen dollars twice
a month to go see bill cosby and riker's
eyes
say what you will about the man the
guy's got fun ideas but i think we're
actually vhs players in the robots or
the iphones like we're on our way out
here
let me even comedy right which is an art
form and you say oh humans robots can
never do it but they absolutely could
like if they like like that song call me
maybe that was a song that was
engineered in a lab it basically took
what humans respond to why can't you do
that with jokes just take words that
humans respond to and do that and it's
like if that if robots start to kill
we're done
dude i genuinely think mark norman was
made by the government
i think i think i think he's the first
one and like he's just out there and
he's a test he could be and he's doing
great what's the deal with robot comedy
do they really have this already
apparently it's like it's probably still
[ __ ] crap it's not no dude robots
can't do stand up
you need to see if the robot could bomb
yeah
how yeah and then get nervous yeah and
embarrassed and embarrassed yeah that's
what you want to see what a waste of a
robot a robot that gets embarrassed
that's the robot i would buy just a
robot that i could share anxiety stories
with and the one i'm like i'm depressed
robot he's like me too
so i go i'll tell you what
i'll drive us down there wow you got the
car i got the car it's sunday no traffic
it's nice and it's rainy you know i'm
like i will get in the car we'll drive
down there love a car so we made a day
of it we drive down to the lower east
fine park i did an amazing parallel
parking job
you got two women in the car forget
about it it's just like you have a
moment of like there's a lot of pressure
i can't [ __ ] up i got to be a man i'm
afraid of the subway yep and i mean i
just
oh i knocked it right in there should
have put a towel down on that uh was it
an escort what do you got there uh
centro centra
yeah something something with vitamins i
said i parked it i was like equidistant
a dick length from both cars two inches
yeah put it in park and i went down i
turned around and i said i want to
genuinely apologize for getting your
[ __ ] so wet
[Music]
you